donc effectivement monsieur le chef de
cabinet on voit que la ministre à sion a
très bien fonctionné puisque en neuf
jours entre le jour de la présentation
au guichet comme vous le dites et
l'octroi du permis
l'afer a été instruite
même si vous le précisez c'est le seul
cas où un collaborateur de l'elysée a
demandé un port d'armes pendant les deux
ans et demi vous avez été présents à ce
poste donc c'était assez exceptionnel
mais vous avez indiqué autre chose
est-ce que vous pouvez confirmer que
donc lorsque la préfecture de police est
saisie d'une demande de port d'armes
le ministère de l'intérieur n'est jamais
interrogé pour savoir si une demande a
été formulée auprès de ses services
première question la deuxième question
c'est avez vous eu connaissance de
menaces dont monsieur benalla aurait
fait l'objet
et vous comprenez bien que c'est lié au
fait qu' il semble donc que ce soit la
seule personne à l'elysée qui soit dans
cette situation puisqu'elle est la seule
personne à pouvoir demander un port
d'armes
il ya d'ailleurs une curiosité à placer
auprès du président de la république
quelqu'un de menaces et bien monsieur
jouer alors je vous avais en partie
répondu à la première question mais
peut-être que vous pourriez re re re
mettre les choses au clair sur la
première question comme je l'aï indiqué
on est sur des fondements juridiques
différents et pan sur des fondements
juridiques différents c'est le stricte
compétence du préfet territorialement
compétent et il n'a pas interrogé le
ministère de l'intérieur
je peux à ma connaissance non la
sénatrice sur la seconde question
excusez moi ça m'a
cette menace sur cette question je ne
suis pas habilité à moi bien je vous
remercie et je voudrais donner la parole
maintenant monsieur segouin vincent
segouin merci monsieur le président euh
ça a été pas mal repris mais je voulais
juste reformuler un peu parce qu'en
effet vous nous expliquer mais je
trouvais je voulais revenir sur l'arrêté
du permis de port d'armes
visionnée par la préfecture monsieur
benalla donc à demander un permis de
port d'armes
uniquement pour sa sécurité personnelle
vous nous expliquer enfin on nous a
expliqué jacques te ment pourtant on
nous a aussi expliqué ce matin au coin
de toutes les auditions que monsieur
ménard est en permanence en à côté du
président sur son épaule droite pour
reprendre ses propos pour assurer la
coordination
si on lui octroie un permis de port
d'armes pour sa sécurité personnelle et
qu'il est à côté du président est-ce
qu'il n'augmente pas le risque de
sécurité au sur la personne du président
c'est ça ma question est la première et
puis est ce que la préfecture
à partir du moment où on respecte les
articles que vous avez mentionné à
plusieurs reprises ne s'inquiète pas
plus du bon sens de la sécurité et ne va
pas plus loin dans l'octroi du permis de
port d'armes monsieur drouet la
préfecture examine examinant droit
les choses et pour être très clair ce
n'est pas pour sa sécurité personnelle
que le port d'armes lui a été octroyé
c'est dans le cadre de ses missions de
sa fonction de la mission qu'on a
considéré comme étant une mission de
police de coordination et du fait qu'il
est dans le cadre de ses fonctions
donc c'est pas à titre personnel dans le
cas de ses fonctions manifestement
exposés à des risques d'agression au
regard du niveau de la menace
effectivement ça ne me paraît pas
aberrant de considérer de considérer
cela merci monsieur drouet